[Music]
deandre hopkins now a member of the
arizona cardinals in large part because
he wanted out of houston and he told
greg bishop of sports illustrated that
he knew how to get out of houston all he
had to do was ask for a little raise by
doing that that would lead to the
outcome that i got which is the outcome
that i wanted and he wanted it in large
part because he had
no relationship with coach bill o'brien
and hopkins told bishop make sure you
put that in there there's not a lot to
speak about as it relates to the
relationship between bill o'brien and
deandre hopkins so one of the best
receivers in the nfl and look if i'm the
cardinals i look at that and say hey
maybe we don't have to pay the guy maybe
maybe he really doesn't want 22 million
a year maybe it was just a ruse to get a
trade and we can go ahead and pay him
under the terms of the current contract
i have a feeling that's not going to
work for steve kyman company but uh
chris far more effective than the george
costanza strategy to get out of the new
york yankees organization didn't have to
drive around in the parking lot with the
super bowl trophies that the texans
don't have or otherwise offend anyone
all he had to say is i want to raise and
the texans moved on from him
well yes i mean the texans a little bit
in a tough spot financially
but you know i just i you know again
i've been around deandre hopkins you you
know that i did a a week with him or a
day with him in the park last year in
new york city you know
well he probably did you're exactly
right but i mean got a great way about
him you know to me like that's
inexcusable on on billy o'brien's part
it really is you know and i i really
admire billy o'brien i think he's a hell
of a football coach we could say what we
want about the gm part of him and all
that all i know as a football coach he
kicks butt and he's one of the better
ones in football but
being a great head coach
part of that is having relationships
with the great players on your football
team and you know that's a dangerous
line to dance with there when you're not
having a relationship with one of the
best guys on your football team you know
it can just filter into bad vibes
throughout your locker room and that's
what i don't understand by that i just
i'm shocked that a guy like billy
o'brien who's so smart and just in my
experience has such a good way with
people
how he could not have a relationship
with deandre hopkins here who's not a
bad guy by any stretch of the
imagination to me is is just
unimaginable i'm just i'm kind of
shocked by that
there was a little bit of acrimony
before hopkins got his current deal when
o'brien was the head coach there was
kind of a hold out that he waited too
long he showed up and then left and that
introduces a completely different
formula that makes it harder for the
player to make a holdout stick so he
showed up he got paid remember he was
one of the players who was offended by
the comment made by the late bob mcnair
the owner and founder of the team about
the the inmates running the prison and
and you you know i'm not defending bill
o'brien here but i can't help but wonder
whether or not he was caught between
maybe an ownership group that was no
longer enamored with deandre hopkins and
hopkins who was alienated with the
ownership group and it just was a matter
of time before it all fell apart anyway
now if you're o'brien i'd like to think
at some level you recognize hey this guy
is one of our core players we have to
find a way to make this work but bottom
line is hopkins had no interest in
making it work he felt no relationship
and
he got what he wanted he moved on
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports